so there's a interesting distinction
that people the program python might be
interested in is def versus FN
so it's two different ways to define a
function
and uh FN is uh a stricter version of
deaf what's the coolness that comes from
the strictness so here you get into what
is the trade-off with the superset yes
okay so superset you have to or you
really want to be compatible if like if
you're doing a superset you've decided
compatibility with existing code is the
important thing even if some of the
decisions they made were maybe not what
you would choose yeah okay so that means
you put a lot of time into compatibility
and it means that you get locked into
decisions of the past
even if they may not have been a good
thing right no systems programmers
typically like to control things right
and they want to make sure that you know
not not all cases of course and no and
even systems programmers are not one
thing right but but often you want
predictability and so one one of the
things that python has for example as
you know is that if you find a variable
you just say x equals four I have a
variable name to X
now I say some long method some some
long name equals 17.
print out some long name
oops by typoed it right well the
compiler the python compiler doesn't
know in all cases what you're defining
what you're using and did you typo the
use of it or the definition right and so
for people coming from type languages
again I'm not saying the right or wrong
but that drives them crazy because they
want the compiler to tell them you typo
the name of this thing right and so what
FN does is it turns on as you say it's a
strict mode and so it says okay well you
have to actually declare intentionally
declare your variables before you use
them that gives you more predictability
more error checking and things like this
but you don't have to uh you don't have
to use it and this is a way that Mojo is
both compatible because deaths work the
same way that deaths have already always
worked but it provides a new alternative
that gives you more control and allows
certain kinds of people that have a
different philosophy to be able to
express that and get that but usually if
you're writing Mojo code from scratch
you'll be using FN
it depends again it depends on your
mentality right it's not it's not the
deaf is Python and FN is Mojo uh Mojo
has both and it loves both right it
really depends on it's just strict yeah
exactly are you are you playing around
and scripting something out is it a
one-off throwaway script cool like
python is great at that I'll still be
using nothing but yeah well so I I love
strictness okay well so control Power
you also like suffering right yes go
hand in hand how many how many pull-ups
I have lost count at this yeah at this
point so I mean that's cool I love you
for that yeah some and I love other
people he likes strict things right but
but I don't want to say that that's the
right thing because Python's also very
beautiful for hacking around and doing
stuff and research and these other cases
where you may not want that you see I
just feel like
oh maybe I'm wrong with that but it
feels like strictness leads to faster
debugging so in terms of going from
even on a small project from zero to
completion it's just I guess it depends
how many bugs you generate usually well
so I mean if it's again Lessons Learned
in looking at the ecosystem it's really
I mean I think it's if you study some of
these languages over time like the Ruby
Community for example now Ruby is a
pretty well developed pretty established
Community but along their path they
really invested in unit testing
like so I think that the Ruby Community
is really pushed forward the state of
the art of testing because they didn't
have a type system that caught a lot of
bugs at compel time right and so you can
have the best of both worlds you can
have good testing and good types right
and things like this but but I thought
that that it was really interesting to
see how certain challenges get solved
and in Python for example
the interactive notebook kind of
experiences and stuff like this are
really amazing if you typo something it
doesn't matter it just tells you it's
fine right and so I think that the
tryouts are very different if you're
building a
um you know large-scale production
system versus you're building and
exploring a notebook and the speaking of
control the hilarious thing if you look
at code I write just for myself for fun
it's like littered with asserts
everywhere okay
it's the kind of uh yeah you would like
to ask it's basically saying uh in a
dictatorial way this should be true now
otherwise everything stops and that that
is the sign I love you man but that is a
sign of somebody who likes control yeah
and so yes I think that you'll like I
think I like Mojo therapy session yes I
definitely will